M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - La commission d'enquête sur le coût réel de l'électricité est ravie d'accueillir M. Jean-Marc Jancovici, ingénieur conseil en énergie-climat.
Vous avez été solicité pour être auditionné dans cette commission d'enquête qui traite du coût de l'énergie et du prix de l'électricité, une demande faite par le groupe Ecologie du Sénat, demande acceptée par le bureau.
je vais vous faire prêter serment, conformément à la procédure applicable aux commissions d'enquête.
Prêtez serment de dire toute la vérité, rien que la vérité, levez la main droite et dites : « Je le jure. »
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici prête serment.)
Vous avez reçu par avance un questionnaire de la part de M. le rapporteur.
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Je ne jurerai pas de cela, mais ce n'est pas important,
car ce que j'ai l'intention de dire, comme en politique, est assez indépendant de la question posée ! (Sourires.)
Quoi qu'il en soit, nous vous demanderons de rester dans les limites du sujet.
Après que vous aurez répondu aux six questions de M. le rapporteur, nous vous interrogerons plus avant le cas échéant.
Vous avez la parole, monsieur le rapporteur.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. -Monsieur Jancovici, je suis désolé que le texte des questions que je souhaitais vous poser aujourd'hui ne vous soit pas parvenu.
Premièrement, comment analysez-vous le récent rapport de la Cour des comptes sur le coût de l'électricité nucléaire ?
Deuxièmement, êtes-vous favorable, notamment pour ce qui concerne le coût de l'électricité, à la prolongation de la durée de vie des centrales nucléaires actuelles
ou au développement d'une nouvelle génération de centrales - EPR ou quatrième génération -, propre à engager la France dans la voie de ce type de production pour le long ou le très long terme ?
N'êtes-vous pas plutôt favorable à un développement des énergies renouvelables ?
Troisièmement, de manière générale, les tarifs actuels de l'électricité vous paraissent-ils refléter fidèlement le « coût réel » de l'électricité ?
Quatrièmement, ces mêmes tarifs vous semblent-ils pertinents d'un point de vue environnemental, au regard du « message » à envoyer aux consommateurs ?
Cinquièmement, quel jugement portez-vous, filière par filière, sur le mécanisme actuel de soutien aux différentes énergies renouvelables et à la cogénération
Sixièmement, le prix de l'électricité en Europe devrait-il mieux refléter le coût lié aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre ?
La prochaine acquisition à titre onéreux desdits quotas par les électriciens va-t-elle dans le bon sens
et aura-t-elle des conséquences sur le prix payé par les consommateurs ?
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - J'espère, monsieur Jancovici, que ces questions ne se trouvent pas à des années-lumière de ce que vous avez préparé ! (Sourires.)
Vous avez la parole.
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Pour étayer mon propos, je vous projetterai un document Powerpoint.
Mon exposé servira d'assise à mes réponses à vos questions, monsieur le rapporteur. Elles tiendront ensuite en peu de mots.
L'essentiel de mon intervention visera à rappeler un fait simple :
l'énergie est avant tout, par définition, la grandeur physique qui caractérise le changement d'état d'un système.
Dire que l'énergie est une grandeur physique signifie qu'elle obéit à un certain nombre de lois.
Les faits scientifiques ne sont pas des opinions : ils s'imposent à nous.
Si l'on essaie de construire l'avenir en les ignorant, on va dans le mur !
Qu'il me soit permis de rappeler quelques éléments de base sur l'énergie.
L'énergie est donc, par définition, ce qui caractérise le changement.
Du point de vue de l'utilisateur, un certain nombre de pratiques, aujourd'hui passées dans la vie courante,
mais de manière très récente à l'échelle de l'histoire de l'humanité, supposent d'utiliser ou de restituer de l'énergie.
C'est le cas si l'on modifie la température dans une pièce,
si l'on met un objet en mouvement ou si on l'arrête,
si l'on change une forme...
Aujourd'hui, le travail de tous les ouvriers d'usine consiste essentiellement à appuyer sur des boutons et à actionner des manettes
afin de piloter des machines pour modifier, changer, déformer, extruder, aplatir, emboutir, etc.
L'ouvrier moderne n'utilise donc pas plus ses muscles que l'employé des services.
Quand un corps se déplace dans un champ avec lequel il interagit, de l'énergie est mise en jeu ;
idem quand une composition atomique change.
Soit dit en passant, toutes les énergies que l'on utilise sur terre dérivent directement ou indirectement de l'énergie nucléaire.
Enfin, l'énergie intervient quand de la matière et du rayonnement interagissent.
Par conséquent, dire que l'on utilise de l'énergie, c'est dire que l'on change le monde qui nous entoure.
La conclusion qui s'impose alors est simple :
l'énergie « propre » n'existe pas puisque, par définition, utiliser de l'énergie, c'est modifier ce qui nous entoure.
Or être propre, n'est-ce pas laisser des lieux dans l'état dans lequel on les a trouvés ?
Quand on utilise de l'énergie, c'est justement pour faire évoluer cet état.
Si l'énergie propre n'existe pas, ce qui peut exister en revanche,
c'est une énergie dont les bénéfices sont significativement plus importants que les inconvénients, ou l'inverse
Comme l'énergie est une grandeur physique, ces différents aspects ne sont qu'une affaire de chiffres.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 3.)
Je vous présenterai maintenant un petit calcul qui rend compte de la totalité du monde qui nous entoure aujourd'hui.
Je soutiens que les 35 heures,
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes, le divorce, les études longues, la tertiarisation de l'économie,
l'étalement urbain, la concentration urbaine, la désertification rurale, etc.,
s'expliquent par la comparaison entre l'énergie que sont capables de fournir nos muscles
et l'énergie qui est associée à toutes les machines que nous employons,
y compris le vidéoprojecteur que j'utilise en ce moment, l'ordinateur dont je me sers,
le métro qui m'a amené ici, le percolateur qui vous a fait le café.
L'organisme d'un humain bien entraîné, par exemple celui d'un militaire du peloton de gendarmerie de haute montagne,
qui gravit le Mont-Blanc et qui pèse 65 kilos restitue environ 0,5 kilowattheure d'énergie mécanique dans cet exercice.
Je ne sais pas si certains d'entre vous ont déjà escaladé le Mont-Blanc en une journée ;
pour l'avoir fait, mais en deux jours,
je puis vous assurer que l'effort est significatif et qu'on ne le répète pas les jours suivants...
Par conséquent, le maximum d'énergie qu'un être humain puisse fournir avec ses jambes,
lesquelles sont dotées des muscles les plus puissants de son organisme,
représente une fraction de kilowattheure par journée de travail.
Admettons que je sois non pas un esclavagiste,
mais un employeur qui rémunère correctement ses employés :
si je paie un homme au SMIC pour pédaler comme un forcené dans une usine,
le kilowattheure d'énergie mécanique produit me reviendra environ 200 euros ;
Quand bien même je ne respecterais aucune des lois sociales en vigueur en France
et traiterais mes employés comme des esclaves, le simple fait de devoir les maintenir en vie,
les nourrir, les protéger du froid, des prédateurs, etc.
me ferait payer le kilowattheure d'énergie mécanique quelques euros ou une dizaine d'euros.
En comparant ce chiffre au coût de l'énergie produite par les machines, on comprend pourquoi l'esclavage a disparu !
s'il utilise ses bras,
la quantité d'énergie restituée sera grosso modo 10 fois inférieure et le coût de revient 10 fois supérieur.
En effet, un litre de notre très chère essence, qui affole tant les foules à l'heure actuelle,
contient environ 10 kilowattheures d'énergie chimique.
Après passage dans un moteur, elle produit quelques kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique.
En termes de coût marginal - hors coût du moteur -,
le kilowattheure d'énergie mécanique issu d'une machine
sera de 1 000 à 10 000 fois moins cher que le kilowattheure produit par un travailleur humain payé au SMIC.
Par conséquent, n'importe quel différentiel de salaire dans le monde se compense par n'importe quel trajet.
En mettant des machines à notre service,
nous avons multiplié notre pouvoir d'achat par 50, par 100 ou par 1 000.
Bref, voilà ce qui permet les acquis sociaux.
Cela a quelques implications.
Tout d'abord, contrairement à une idée répandue, le prix réel de l'énergie,
depuis que nous en utilisons, n'a pas augmenté ; il a même considérablement décru.
Le prix réel correspond au temps de travail nécessaire pour acquérir un kilowattheure.
Cette durée est la seule unité constante dans le temps pour mesurer le prix réel d'une chose.
Toute autre unité monétaire est trompeuse, en particulier le prix en monnaie courante,
voire le prix en monnaie constante, qui doit être ramené à ce que les gens gagnent :
si la fiche de paie augmente plus vite que le prix en monnaie constante, le prix réel n'augmente pas ; il baisse.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 4.)
Cette courbe retrace le prix du pétrole, qui est le prix directeur de toutes les autres énergies, depuis 1860.
On constate qu'en monnaie constante le prix du baril de pétrole entre 1880
- auparavant, il a décru parallèlement à celui de l'huile de baleine, la source d'énergie concurrente -
et 1970 est resté relativement stable, aux alentours de 20 dollars.
Dans le même temps, la rémunération du consommateur occidental a été multipliée par 15-20,
ce qui revient à dire que le prix du litre de pétrole a été divisé par 15-20.
En outre, ma corporation, celle des ingénieurs, ayant remarquablement travaillé et
multiplié par un facteur compris entre 2-10 l'efficacité mécanique de l'utilisation d'un litre de pétrole,
le coût réel dukWh fourni par l'esclave énergétique qu'est la machine a été divisé par 50-100 en l'espace de 100 ans.
Le prix réel - c'est-à-dire exprimé en temps de travail - de n'importe quel objet pouvant être acquis aujourd'hui
- une table, une chaise, une paire de lunettes, une chemise - et existant déjà il y a un siècle
a été divisé par un facteur allant de 50 à 100.
C'est ce que l'on appelle l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat.
Cette augmentation peut se ramener, en première approximation - j'insiste bien sur ce point -, à la baisse du prix réel de l'énergie.
Même au cours des périodes récentes, contrairement à l'idée répandue, le prix de l'énergie a continué de baisser.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 5.)
Ce superbe graphique, issu de l'excellent Service de l'observation et des statistiques,
présente l'évolution des dépenses de carburants, d'électricité, de gaz et autres combustibles des ménages français depuis 1970.
Comme ces dépenses augmentent, on se dit que les gens paient leur énergie de plus en plus cher.
En fait, la donnée importante est leur part dans le budget des ménages,
autrement dit la part du temps de travail consacrée à l'achat de l'énergie
En prenant ce paramètre en considération, on s'aperçoit que l'énergie coûte moins cher aujourd'hui qu'avant le premier choc pétrolier.
Encore une fois, contrairement à une idée très répandue, l'énergie coûte de moins en moins cher.
En fait, son coût est passé, au cours des quarante dernières années, de rien à encore moins que rien :
j'ai montré tout à l'heure que l'énergie mécanique valait entre 1/1000e et 1/10.000e du coût du travail humain.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 6.)
Quel type d'énergie utilisons-nous en France ? Les journalistes, dans notre pays, confondent en permanence énergie et électricité,
au motif que les seuls dispositifs de production français sont non pas des puits de pétrole ou de gaz ni des mines de charbon,
mais des centrales électriques, les journalistes, dans notre pays, confondent en permanence énergie et électricité...
Les Français consomment, pour l'essentiel, des combustibles fossiles importés.
Il faut pomper un peu pour les extraire du sous-sol, mais également les transporter.
La part du pétrole dans la consommation énergétique des Français est exactement identique à ce qu'elle est dans la consommation des Britanniques, des Allemands
ou des Italiens, les Américains n'utilisant guère plus de pétrole que nous.
Contrairement à une idée courante, le recours au nucléaire ne sert pas à éviter d'utiliser du pétrole ;
il sert à éviter de consommer du gaz et du charbon, ce qui, selon moi, est une excellente idée.
Vous pouvez constater, sur ce graphique, que la part du chauffage électrique est importante,
mais qu'elle est loin de constituer l'essentiel du total.
Notez également que, pour le résidentiel et le tertiaire, le chauffage consomme moins d'électricité que les autres usages.
Autrement dit, la consommation d'électricité qui augmente le plus vite aujourd'hui dans les bâtiments n'est pas celle qui est liée au chauffage,
mais celle qui sert à faire fonctionner tout le reste :
les machines qui montent et qui descendent, qui cuisent, qui refroidissent, qui tournent, qui retransmettent des tas d'images extraordinaires, etc.
Bref, le chauffage ne représente pas l'essentiel de la consommation électrique dans les bâtiments.
Selon moi, il est très important de garder en tête un raisonnement macroéconomique :
la notion microéconomique de coût et de prix n'a pas nécessairement beaucoup de sens.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Que signifie « ECS » dans le tableau ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Eau chaude sanitaire.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Et « autres » ? Ce sont tous les appareils électriques ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Chauffage et ECS constituent les usages thermiques de l'électricité.
La catégorie « autres » recouvre les usages spécifiques : tous les moteurs électriques, les réfrigérateurs,
les pompes, les machines à laver, les appareils audiovisuels, les ampoules électriques...
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - La consommation d'électricité est supérieure pour ces usages spécifiques ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Oui, et elle croît plus vite !
Je n'ai pas indiqué, dans le schéma, l'évolution de la consommation électrique dans les bâtiments en France.
De mémoire, elle est passée, entre 1970 et aujourd'hui, de 50 TWh à 250-300 TWh.
L'essentiel de l'augmentation est imputable au poste « autres », et non au chauffage électrique.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 7.)
L'une des conclusions que je tire des éléments précédents est que les outils de pilotage macroéconomique dont nous disposons aujourd'hui sont totalement trompeurs.
C'est l'un des problèmes sur lesquels on bute souvent lorsqu'on établit des comparaisons économiques.
Selon l'économie que nous avons apprise à l'école, il y a deux facteurs de production : le capital et le travail.
Quand le PIB « flageole » - ce qui ne manque pas d'inquiéter fortement tous les élus ! -, on détaxe un peu le travail et
on injecte du crédit pour augmenter le capital, afin que le PIB reprenne du souffle.
En fait, cela ne fonctionne pas : depuis maintenant quarante ans, il y a trop de travail - le chômage est structurel -
et trop de capital - de nombreuses bulles spéculatives se forment -, et pourtant le PIB est flageolant !
Cela signifie que le schéma que j'ai décrit n'est pas le bon.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 8.)
La bonne représentation du système est la suivante :
la machine économique mondiale n'est qu'une machine à transformer en autre chose des ressources gratuites grâce à du travail,
fourni par des êtres humains ou des machines.
Tout ce qui se trouve dans cette salle, mesdames, messieurs les sénateurs,
tout ce qui s'offrira à votre regard quand vous en sortirez
n'est rien d'autre que de la ressource naturelle transformée par l'action de l'homme.
Les ressources naturelles sont le fruit de 15 Mds d'années d'évolution depuis le big bang et elles sont gratuites,
y compris le pétrole, le gaz, le charbon, l'uranium.
Les partisans des énergies renouvelables affirment souvent que le vent et le soleil sont gratuits, mais il en est de même de toutes les autres sources d'énergie.
Ce qui coûte pour le pétrole, par exemple, c'est l'accès à la ressource, qui a la mauvaise idée de se trouver sous les pieds de M. Dupont et pas sous ceux de M. Durand !
Cependant, la formation de la ressource est gratuite : personne n'a payé le moindre centime pour que se constituent les réserves de pétrole,
les atomes de fer, de cuivre, de manganèse, ainsi que tout le patrimoine de la biodiversité.
Ces ressources gratuites sont captées et transformées grâce à notre travail afin de devenir autre chose.
Par ailleurs, la formation de capital ne représente qu'une boucle interne au système.
Le capital, par exemple l'immeuble dans lequel nous sommes, c'est des ressources et du travail passés.
Dans ce schéma, comme je l'ai indiqué tout à l'heure, le travail qui permet de transformer les ressources
est fourni par nos muscles et par les machines dans un rapport de 1 à 200.
Cette représentation éclaire ce qui se passe depuis trente-cinq ans :
s'il y a un problème de volume disponible pour l'énergie - et c'est bien de cela qu'il s'agit, et non d'un problème de prix -,
il y a un problème de volume pour le PIB, quel que soit le prix auquel les gens ont accès à l'énergie.
Je prendrai un exemple caricatural à cet égard. Si demain matin le carburant est rationné et les volumes disponibles divisés par dix,
peu importe que les gens paient le litre de carburant 50 centimes, 1 euro ou 1,5 euro plus cher :
les flux de transport seront instantanément divisés par dix et, en première approximation, le PIB français sera divisé par un chiffre compris entre cinq et vingt.
Ce n'est pas une question de prix de l'énergie, c'est une question de quantité disponible.
Dans un marché parfait, les deux paramètres sont corrélés, mais le marché n'est pas parfait et une foule de régulations
- rationnements, quotas, normes, interdictions - interviennent hors marché.
Dans le monde réel, les prix et les volumes ne sont pas parfaitement asservis par le jeu de phénomènes totalement lisses.
Ce qui compte, encore une fois, ce sont les volumes.
C'est exactement ce que l'on observe en France depuis le premier choc pétrolier :
une contrainte pèse sur les volumes, contrainte qui a fait régresser la croissance du PIB de 3 % à 1 % par an,
d'où un chômage structurel et un tas de petits inconvénients qui ne sont pas à la veille d'être résolus...
S'il y a en plus une pression sur les ressources, il y aura également une pression sur la production, quelle que soit la quantité d'énergie disponible.
Par exemple, si la ressource en poissons est épuisée,
vous aurez beau armer tous les chalutiers du monde avec toute l'énergie disponible,
ils ne prendront aucun poisson et le PIB de la pêche sera nul.
Or, j'insiste, ni le stock de poissons ni le stock de pétrole ne sont nulle part valorisés dans les représentations économiques.
Par conséquent, le prix de l'énergie ne donne qu'une vision très partielle de l'importance du système énergétique
dans le fonctionnement des sociétés modernes.
Les déterminants du premier ordre sont le volume disponible et celui que je peux obtenir.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 9.)
Voilà un premier graphique qui accrédite mes propos.
Il retrace la variation depuis 1961 de la consommation d'énergie de la planète, en violet, et celle du PIB mondial, en bleu.
Les deux sont extrêmement bien corrélées, conformément à ce que je viens de vous dire.
La première partie de mon intervention peut se résumer ainsi :
Mère Nature nous a donné gratuitement des combustibles fossiles,
qui alimentent les moteurs et la chimie, lesquels font fonctionner la totalité des machines qui nous entourent ;
par ricochet, cela a induit une très forte hausse de la productivité du travail, qui a structuré l'ensemble de nos acquis sociaux.
Même le divorce est un fruit de ce phénomène :
en effet, un divorce amène un doublement des besoins en logement - la crise du logement est notamment due au divorce -
et par voie de conséquence de la consommation d'énergie pour le chauffage et la fabrication de tous les objets de la vie courante,
sans parler du transport des éventuels enfants d'un domicile à l'autre ou de la facture du psychiatre,
la garde alternée étant très néfaste à l'équilibre mental de ces derniers,
ainsi qu'une étude épidémiologique récente vient de le démontrer... Ce n'est pas une blague :
il est prouvé que le divorce augmente instantanément la consommation d'énergie des ex-conjoints d'environ 60 % :
on ne divorce pas dans les pays qui manquent d'énergie.
L'urbanisation croissante est une fonction de l'énergie croissante. Pourquoi ?
Parce que quand une énergie abondante permet de faire fonctionner de nombreuses machines,
il devient possible de retirer les agriculteurs des champs et les ouvriers des usines pour les employer dans des bureaux,
où leur fonction sera d'échanger des informations, comme nous le faisons actuellement ou
Nous ne produisons rien de physique, nous échangeons des informations,
comme le font les comptables, les banquiers, le personnel de la sécurité sociale.
Si nous pouvons le faire, c'est parce que, ailleurs, des machines s'occupent des flux physiques à notre place et
fabriquent des vêtements, de la nourriture, des voitures, des logements, etc.
En cela, une société fortement urbanisée et fortement tertiarisée n'est pas une société fortement dématérialisée ;
elle est, au contraire, l'aboutissement ultime d'une société fortement consommatrice d'énergie.
Si je vous montrais la courbe de la consommation d'énergie par personne en fonction de la part du tertiaire dans l'emploi,
vous pourriez constater qu'il existe une très belle corrélation à la hausse mais pas du tout à la baisse.
De plus, le tertiaire comprend tous les services de transport, qui ne sont pas spécialement dématérialisés.
L'énergie, et non la technique, a joué un rôle central dans cette évolution.
La technique permet de construire un ordinateur ; pour que chacun puisse avoir un ordinateur à 500 euros, il faut de l'énergie à gogo :
surtout pour la fabrication, un peu pour le fonctionnement.
À ce stade, deux questions d'une importance déterminante se posent :
1) y a-t-il un goulet d'étranglement en amont en ce qui concerne l'accès aux combustibles fossiles ?
2) y a-t-il un goulet d'étranglement en aval au regard du changement climatique induit par la libération de CO2 dans l'atmosphère ?
Pour répondre à la première question, il faut faire appel à un petit théorème de mathématiques.
Les combustibles fossiles mettent des centaines de millions d'années à se former :
300 millions pour le charbon et 100 millions pour le pétrole.
Aux échelles de temps qui nous intéressent, nous pouvons donc considérer que le stock extractible de combustibles fossiles est donné une fois pour toutes,
même si l'on ne connaît pas à l'avance son niveau.
Lorsqu'on puise dans un stock donné une fois pour toutes, l'extraction ne peut aller indéfiniment croissant.
Elle ne peut même pas être indéfiniment constante :
Cela se démontre, l'exploitation du stock part de zéro, se termine à zéro et passe par un maximum entre les deux.
et c'est vrai pour le pétrole, pour le gaz, pour le charbon, pour tous les minerais métalliques de cette bonne vieille terre.
Pour toutes ces matières premières, il existe donc une entité mathématique qui s'appelle le « pic ».
Celui-ci peut avoir déjà été atteint ou ne devoir l'être que dans un avenir éloigné ;
il peut s'établir au niveau actuel de production ou à un niveau bien supérieur.
Mais l'existence de cette entité est démontrée et son apparition est inéluctable.
En ce qui concerne le pétrole, un premier pic est très facile à discerner : le pic des découvertes, qui est déjà passé.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 12.)
Cette courbe, qui retrace les découvertes annuelles de réserves de pétrole extractibles, est passée par un maximum en 1964.
À l'heure actuelle, un peu plus de 2 000 milliards de barils ont été découverts. (Un baril fait 159 litres, unité favorite des américains mais non-conventionnelle)
La quantité extraite a crû jusqu'en 2005 et s'est stabilisée depuis cette date.
Elle représente au total environ 1 200 milliards de barils, soit à peu près la moitié de ce qui a été découvert.
Compte tenu du délai moyen qui sépare l'apparition du pic des découvertes de celle du pic de production,
donnée qui se vérifie dans toutes les grandes zones pétrolières, nous sommes au maximum de la production mondiale de pétrole.
L'Agence internationale de l'énergie a même avoué que le pic de production avait été atteint en 2006.
En première approximation, retenons simplement que la production annuelle de pétrole est désormais stable.
Cette période de stabilité durera plus ou moins longtemps,
selon le rythme d'extraction des stocks déjà connus et celui des nouvelles découvertes.
Nous sommes donc très loin des 50 milliards de barils annuels de nouvelles réserves de l'âge d'or des découvertes,
quand les ingénieurs de Schlumberger exploraient le sous-sol des pays bordant le golfe Persique.
Aujourd'hui, quand on découvre un gisement de seulement quelques milliards de barils, cela semble mirifique !
Le « plateau » de production durera jusqu'aux alentours de 2020, puis nous assisterons à un déclin absolument inexorable,
n'en déplaise aux automobilistes français, aux gestionnaires de turbines à fioul ou aux utilisateurs de fioul lourd.
Quel sera le prix du pétrole à ce moment-là ? Selon moi, ce n'est pas le sujet.
Comme je l'ai déjà souligné, ce qui importe, ce sont les volumes.
Par ailleurs, au vu des expériences passées, il convient de rester extrêmement modeste quand on se risque à faire des prévisions :
on gagne du temps à ne pas écouter ceux qui annoncent une prévision de prix à vingt ans pour le pétrole !
La seule certitude est que les cours vont devenir volatils.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 13.)
Voici un comparatif entre les prix réels du pétrole constatés jusqu'en 2010
et les prévisions de prix établies, année après année, par l'Agence internationale de l'énergie : il y a de quoi rire !
Il est impossible de prédire l'évolution du prix d'une matière première aussi essentielle que le pétrole,
dont le marché comporte énormément de biais et d'incertitudes.
Je ne sais pas quel sera le prix du pétrole à l'avenir, mais encore une fois là n'est pas la question : ce qui importe, ce sont les volumes.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 14.)
Une règle de trois fait apparaître pourquoi l'énergie et le PIB - ou GDP, gross domestic product - sont si fortement liés.
Le PIB par habitant, c'est-à-dire le pouvoir d'achat, est égal au produit de l'énergie par personne par la quantité d'énergie nécessaire pour obtenir 1 dollar de PIB,
qui mesure l'efficacité énergétique de l'économie.
Intéressons-nous maintenant aux variations. Vous savez que la variation d'un produit est la somme des variations de ses termes.
La croissance du PIB par personne est donc la somme de la croissance de l'énergie par personne - voilà pourquoi cet élément est si structurant -
et de celle de l'efficacité énergétique de l'économie.
La première, en moyenne mondiale, a crû de 2 % par an entre le début de la révolution industrielle et 1980.
Après cette date, sa croissance est devenue presque nulle.
Quant à l'efficacité énergétique de l'économie, elle augmente de 1 % par an depuis 1970.
Tout cela signifie que la croissance du PIB par habitant, qui concerne essentiellement les économies dites « développées » jusqu'en 1990-1995,
est passée brutalement à partir de 1980, pour des raisons physiques,
de 3 % à 1 % par an, ce qui a entraîné l'apparition puis l'augmentation de la dette des États souverains,
l'endettement des ménages et des entreprises, la volatilité des prix de l'énergie,
l'émergence du chômage structurel, bref tous les petits désagréments que l'on nous promet de régler après la prochaine élection,
mais qui ne le seront bien évidemment pas, sauf mise en oeuvre d'un nouveau « plan Marshall ».
En conclusion, toute réflexion prospective sur le prix de l'énergie doit prendre en compte le fait qu'il n'y aura pas de retour de la croissance : je n'y crois pas.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Votre démonstration vaut pour la France ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Elle vaut pour n'importe quel pays.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Le sigle « NRJ » recouvre le volume d'énergie ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Oui, le volume et non le prix. Le terme « NRJ/POP » désigne la quantité d'énergie par personne et par an, exprimée en kilowattheures.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Comment calculez-vous ces chiffres ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Il suffit de diviser la production mondiale d'énergie par la population mondiale.
Production mondiale d'énergie - issue du pétrole, du gaz, des centrales nucléaires et hydrauliques, de la biomasse, le reste étant négligeable - divisée par la population mondiale.
Toutes les énergies peuvent s'exprimer en kilowattheures.
Ce petit calcul prouve que toute réflexion prospective sur les investissements dans les infrastructures énergétiques doit, à mon sens,
s'envisager dans un contexte où nous ne retrouverons pas une croissance économique forte.
Est-ce un bien ou un mal ? Là n'est pas la question. Si gérer, c'est prévoir, il faut avoir cette donnée en tête.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 15.)
Voilà une illustration de cette corrélation entre énergie et PIB à partir de 1968. L'évolution de la production mondiale de pétrole est figurée en violet.
Il s'agit bien de la production, et non du prix. La variation du PIB par personne est figurée en bleu, le tout à partir de 1968.
Contrairement à une idée répandue, la co-variation des deux courbes est meilleure à partir de la fin des années quatre-vingt qu'auparavant, époque où la production de pétrole pouvait varier plus fortement sans trop affecter le PIB,
et l'économie n'est pas moins sensible aujourd'hui qu'hier à la quantité de pétrole accessible, bien au contraire :
les transports tiennent une place plus importante dans une économie mondialisée.
Vous pouvez également constater qu'au cours des deux derniers épisodes de crise, la chute du PIB n'a pas entraîné celle de la production de pétrole ;
c'est l'inverse qui s'est produit. C'est le reflet de l'effet « volume ».
Lorsque l'offre de pétrole est réduite brutalement, cela provoque, outre une hausse du prix, une baisse du PIB, celui-ci étant piloté par le volume de pétrole.
Cette baisse n'est pas simplement due à l'effet inflationniste de la hausse du prix du pétrole.
Que se passera-t-il, à l'avenir, en ce qui concerne le volume de pétrole ?
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 16.)
Ce graphique représente la quantité totale de pétrole à disposition de l'Europe depuis 1965.
La production domestique est figurée en rose, avec un petit talon de production provenant historiquement des pays de l'Est situés non loin de la mer Caspienne.
Est également prise en compte la production de la mer du Nord - dont celle de la Norvège -, qui a connu un pic en 2000 et qui décline, depuis, à raison de 5 % à 8 % par an.
Les importations en provenance du reste du monde sont figurées en vert.
On constate que les importations représentent l'essentiel du pétrole consommé par les Européens, ici l'UE + la Norvège - bonne partie de la production européenne en rose -.
Le début du déclin « terminal » de l'accès européen au pétrole date, selon moi, de 2005.
Depuis cette date, le volume de pétrole à la disposition de l'Europe a diminué de 8 %.
La production mondiale étant désormais stable, en raison de l'effet d'éviction dû aux pays émergents et aux pays producteurs eux-mêmes,
la fraction résiduelle mise sur le marché mondial baisse.
Les importations et la production européennes décroissent, par conséquent la quantité de pétrole disponible en Europe diminue.
Or, en l'état actuel des choses, il n'y a que deux manières de faire baisser la consommation de pétrole : par la hausse des prix, forte et non régulée, ou par la récession.
Mon sentiment est que nous entrons maintenant dans une ère nouvelle de l'économie européenne,
qui sera marquée par de fortes hausses du prix du pétrole et la récession.
C'est dans ce contexte qu'il faudra envisager nos investissements électriques.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 17.)
Voilà comment se décompose le prix du litre de super dont il a beaucoup été question il n'y a pas si longtemps.
Pour l'essentiel, le prix de l'essence est constitué de taxes, qui ne sont pas seulement prélevées par la France.
Les taxes encaissées par les États producteurs constituent un quart du prix. La TIPP compte pour 41 %, la TVA pour 16 % et la part de l'« affreux » Total pour 5 %.
Une éventuelle suppression de la marge de Total - 10 milliards d'euros  - ne réduirait que très faiblement le prix du carburant à la pompe pour le consommateur :
la baisse serait de l'ordre de 5 centimes. Les ordres de grandeur ne seraient pas modifiés.
En particulier, cela ne changerait rien aux paramètres liés à la rareté de la ressource
ni aux dépenses d'extraction, les coûts marginaux de celle-ci augmentant très fortement pour les nouveaux gisements mis en exploitation.
Voilà pourquoi je pense le plus grand mal de l'instauration d'une TIPP flottante. Selon moi, il s'agirait d'une subvention directe aux exportations du Qatar, de la Russie et de la Libye.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - L'application de la TIPP flottante serait limitée dans le temps. Il s'agit de permettre aux entrepreneurs de respecter leurs devis.
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - C'est une mesure fondée sur l'idée que le prix du pétrole finira par se stabiliser, or cela ne pourra arriver que dans un contexte de récession.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - D'accord !
Instaurer la TIPP flottante revient donc à appauvrir l'État tant que le pétrole continue à se vendre, avant que cet appauvrissement ne s'aggrave avec la récession.
Je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit la façon la plus intelligente d'utiliser l'argent public.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 18.)
Le gaz se formant géologiquement aux mêmes endroits que le pétrole, il est découvert à peu près en même temps que lui.
Au début, le gaz n'intéressait pas du tout les pétroliers. Trouver du gaz était même, pour eux, une véritable calamité.
Ce n'est plus le cas à l'heure actuelle.
Ils n'aimaient pas trouver du gaz pour une raison simple :
contrairement au pétrole, le gaz coûte plus cher à transporter qu'à extraire.
Le pétrole étant liquide à température ordinaire, il se transporte avec une densité d'énergie par unité de volume beaucoup plus importante que le gaz, qui obéit à la loi de Mariotte, et donc à un coût moins élevé.
Voilà pourquoi les 2/3 du pétrole extrait sur Terre passent une frontière avant d'être consommés.
Cela n'est vrai que pour 25 % du gaz, le gaz naturel liquéfié représentant en particulier 8 % de la consommation mondiale de gaz.
La seule vraie énergie internationale est donc le pétrole.
Toutes les autres énergies sont des énergies régionales, comme le gaz, ou domestiques, comme le charbon.
Le pic des découvertes de gisements gaziers a déjà été passé depuis longtemps. Comme pour le pétrole, la production va monter puis se réduire.
On raclera les réservoirs, ce qui sera plus difficile à faire que pour le pétrole.
Le pic de production interviendra, selon les régions, entre maintenant et 2050.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 19.)
Voilà maintenant un graphique qui figure l'approvisionnement gazier de l'Europe.
On observe une proportion inverse à celle constatée pour le pétrole.
Les importations ne représentent que 40 % du total, mais le pic de production des gisements de la mer du Nord, d'où proviennent les 60 % restants, a été passé dans les années 2000.
La production européenne est en léger déclin pour le moment, mais la tendance s'accélérera fortement lorsque la Norvège passera également son pic, d'ici à 2020.
Par conséquent, le remplacement, même en période de transition énergétique, de la moindre centrale nucléaire en Europe par du gaz se fera nécessairement au détriment d'une consommation de gaz ailleurs.
On ne peut pas accroître la production actuelle de l'Europe, qui est déjà en baisse.
La récente décision de Mme Merkel de relancer le plan Schröder et de remplacer le nucléaire allemand par du gaz russe aura un effet d'éviction direct sur le consommateur français.
Les textes européens n'interdisent pas à l'Allemagne de faire un tel choix, mais la France doit bien comprendre ce que cela signifie pour elle, un effet d'éviction direct pour le français.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 20.)
Ce que la presse désigne de manière erronée sous le nom de gaz de schiste - pour l'essentiel, ce n'en sont pas - correspond en fait à ce que l'on appelle les gaz non conventionnels, catégorie qui recouvre trois familles de gaz.
1) La moins importante d'entre elles est celle des gaz de schiste, ou plus exactement de roche-mère.
Ces gaz se sont formés dans la roche qui contenait les sédiments organiques à l'origine de la formation du pétrole et du gaz et n'ont pas quitté cette roche.
2) La deuxième famille est celle des gaz de charbon. Il s'agit tout simplement du grisou, que l'on récupère en fracturant les veines de charbon et qui est composé essentiellement de méthane.
3) La troisième famille est celle des gaz de réservoir compact, qui ont migré depuis la roche-mère où ils se sont formés vers une roche-réservoir, où ils se sont accumulés,
comme pour le gaz ordinaire, à la particularité près que la roche-réservoir s'est par la suite un peu resédimentée. La perméabilité n'est donc plus assurée, et il faut la recréer en fracturant la roche-réservoir.
Il s'agit également de techniques de fracturation, comme pour le gaz de schiste, mais sur le plan géologique cela n'a rien à voir.
On trouve du gaz de réservoir compact là où il y a du gaz tout court. On peut trouver du gaz de roche-mère là où il y a des roches-mères, mais ce n'est nullement une certitude :
depuis la surface, on peut seulement savoir s'il y a des roches-mères ;
pour savoir si elles contiennent du gaz, il faut forer.
À titre indicatif, lorsque l'on soupçonne, après « échographie », qu'une formation géologique contient du pétrole, les forages d'exploration ne donnent rien 5 fois sur 6.
Avons-nous en France des gaz de schiste ? On ne peut pas le savoir tant qu'on n'a pas foré.
Y a-t-il en Europe des gaz de réservoir compact ? La réponse est non. Y a-t-il du gaz de charbon ?
Pour les pays qui ont des gisements de charbon, la réponse est oui ; pour la France, où il reste très peu de charbon, la réponse est non.
Confondre gaz de schiste et gaz non conventionnels, schiste et gaz de schiste et tout extrapoler à la France est un mauvais raccourci médiatique.
En réalité, nous ne savons pas si un approvisionnement en gaz de schiste est possible en France.
Quand bien même cela le serait, l'exploitation du gaz de schiste est considérablement plus capitalistique que celle du gaz conventionnel.
Tout le gaz du gisement de Lacq a été extrait par un seul forage d'exploitation. Pour les gaz non conventionnels,
un puits draine une surface d'environ un kilomètre carré. Il faut donc forer un puits tous les kilomètres pour exploiter un gisement :
je vous laisse imaginer ce que cela donnerait dans les Cévennes ! Il faut donc pouvoir forer facilement et disposer de suffisamment de capitaux pour le faire en permanence.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 21.)
Quelles sources d'énergie sont utilisées en Europe pour fabriquer de l'électricité ?
Contrairement à la réponse couramment donnée à l'occasion d'un sondage réalisé aux États-Unis, l'électricité ne sort pas du mur, il faut la produire.
En Europe, l'électricité provient en grande partie du charbon. Il entre pour moitié dans la fabrication de l'électricité allemande.
Du reste, l'Energiekonzept allemand, ce n'est pas de construire principalement des éoliennes, c'est essentiellement de produire de l'électricité à partir du charbon et du gaz.
L'Allemagne construit actuellement 20 gigawatts de capacité fossile pour pouvoir décommissionner les 23 gigawatts de production nucléaire actuellement en service.
Avec un peu de chance, la population allemande diminuera suffisamment rapidement pour que les émissions de CO2 du pays n'augmentent pas.
En tout état de cause, le plan allemand de transition énergétique repose sur l'effet combiné du vieillissement de la population et de l'augmentation de la consommation de gaz et de charbon.
La presse française applaudit des deux mains, mais j'ai quelques doutes sur l'intérêt écologique du système...
Le charbon fournit donc un tiers de l'électricité européenne, le gaz entre 15 % et 20 %.
Comme je l'ai souligné, la quantité de gaz disponible est déjà en baisse.
Viennent ensuite l'hydroélectricité et l'éolien.
À l'échelle européenne, l'éolien n'est pas significatif aujourd'hui.
Peut-il le devenir ? Ne disposant pas d'assez de temps pour répondre à cette question aujourd'hui, je me bornerai à quelques observations.
Il n'existe pas, aujourd'hui, de foisonnement éolien en Europe. Il est faux de prétendre le contraire.
Soit une dépression est installée sur la façade atlantique et les éoliennes injectent leur production électrique sur le réseau, de l'Espagne à la Grande-Bretagne en passant par l'Allemagne et la France, soit il n'y a pas de dépression et donc pratiquement pas de production.
Il n'existe pas d'effet de compensation entre le nord et le sud de l'Europe.
Par ailleurs, je suis favorable à ce qu'on limite le bénéfice des tarifs de rachat à la production électrique dont la disponibilité est garantie de façon permanente.
Sinon, cela signifie que l'intermittence induite est mise à la charge d'un autre acteur du réseau, sans que celui-ci soit prévenu ni même désigné.
L'intermittence induite oblige d'autres acteurs à prévoir des moyens de back up, de stockage ou d'effacement de consommation.
En gros, dans la situation actuelle, on subventionne le producteur d'énergie éolienne pour introduire de l'intermittence dans le réseau électrique et on impose à d'autres d'assumer les surcoûts qui en découlent.
Il serait préférable, à mon sens, de distinguer deux sous-catégories au sein des tarifs de rachat :
A) l'une pour le kilowattheure garanti, à savoir celui qui est fourni de manière certaine quand on en a besoin - la production hydroélectrique entre dans cette sous-catégorie -,
B) l'autre pour le kilowattheure injecté dans le réseau au gré de la production, ce dernier valant nécessairement moins cher. Je reviendrai sur ce point tout à l'heure.
Il y a donc des distinctions à faire entre les énergies renouvelables.
La production électrique est mieux garantie à partir d'un stock de bois, qui peut être consommé à la demande, qu'à partir de l'éolien, qui fournit de l'électricité uniquement quand le vent souffle.
Dans la mesure où l'électricité ne se stocke pas en tant que telle - on stocke de l'eau en altitude ou une séparation chimique dans une batterie -,
une source intermittente a nécessairement moins de valeur pour un réseau électrique qu'une source garantie et pilotable.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 22.)
Comment vont évoluer les prix exogènes, c'est-à-dire ne dépendant pas des décisions françaises ?
Le prix du charbon est figuré dans le graphique de gauche. Il entre pour environ 50 % dans le coût de la production électrique issue du charbon.
Le prix du charbon est très bien corrélé à celui du pétrole.
Par conséquent, comme le prix du pétrole augmentera, sauf récession, celui du charbon suivra la même tendance.
Le prix du gaz - qui constitue 70 % du coût de production du kilowattheure produit à partir du gaz - est figuré dans le graphique de droite.
Il a évolué de façon identique au niveau mondial, jusqu'au moment où les États-Unis se sont fortement décorrélés des autres zones, pour des raisons de production domestique,
ce qui ne changera rien au destin des Européens, comme nous avons pu le constater récemment. Pour l'Europe, le prix du gaz continuera d'être asservi à celui du pétrole.
L'électricité produite à partir du gaz, 70% du prix du kWh, coûtera donc plus cher.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 23.)
J'en viens à l'hydroélectricité. Voilà un modèle qui présente une synthèse des simulations issues du dernier rapport du groupe d'experts intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du climat, le GIEC.
Il établit l'évolution des précipitations sur la planète selon un scénario qualifié de « charbon haut »,
c'est-à-dire caractérisé par une utilisation maximale du charbon consommable, avec un pic aux alentours de 2050.
Il fait apparaître l'évolution des précipitations en hiver et en été dans l'hémisphère Nord :
on constate que le pourtour du bassin méditerranéen s'assèche en toutes saisons et pour tous les modèles.
La production hydroélectrique européenne va probablement diminuer.
Or l'hydroélectricité est la plus précieuse de toutes les formes de production électrique, car c'est la mieux modulable et la plus pilotable.
La seule installation capable de délivrer 2 gigawatts dans un délai de trois minutes est un barrage.
Aucune autre forme de production électrique n'en est capable ! La contrainte climatique ne sera donc pas sans incidences.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Comment voyez-vous cette évolution sur la carte ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Les zones colorées en rouge s'assèchent et les précipitations augmentent dans les zones en bleu.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - C'est une carte de la situation actuelle ?
Non, elle présente l'évolution d'ici à la fin du siècle. En gros, l'Europe devrait avoir perdu de 20 % à 30 % de ses précipitations à cette échéance, mais de façon non continue.
Il y aura des à-coups, comme en 2003 ou en 2010. Nous connaîtrons de plus en plus des situations de mise sous tension du système.
Les épisodes caniculaires importants ou de grande sécheresse présentent deux inconvénients importants :
d'une part, les barrages se remplissent moins bien ;
d'autre part, le refroidissement des centrales thermiques devient problématique.
Or les centrales thermiques - nucléaire, gaz et charbon - représentent environ 75 % de la production d'électricité européenne.
En 2003, sur les treize dérogations demandées par EDF pour ses centrales thermiques, sept concernaient des centrales nucléaires, et six des centrales à charbon ou à pétrole.
Comme nous avons l'association « Sortir du nucléaire », la presse a largement parlé des centrales nucléaires, et pas des centrales à charbon ou à gaz.
Néanmoins, la problématique est identique pour toutes les centrales thermiques.
Le TGV qui se rend à Marseille passe à proximité de la centrale à charbon de Gardanne, qui est équipée de très beaux aéro-réfrigérants.
Si l'on demande aux voyageurs de quoi il s'agit - je fais souvent ce test -, ils répondent que c'est une centrale nucléaire !
Dans la même situation, un Américain pensera à une centrale à charbon.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 24.)
Je terminerai mon exposé par les énergies renouvelables.
Ce graphique retrace la contribution des énergies renouvelables au bilan énergétique mondial en 2010.
L'unité utilisée est le million de tonnes équivalent pétrole (1 Tep = 11.630 kWh = 41,86 GJ).
La consommation mondiale équivaut à 14 000 millions de tonnes équivalent pétrole.
La première énergie renouvelable est de très loin le bois, qui couvre environ 10 % de la consommation mondiale d'énergie.
Vient ensuite l'hydroélectricité, qui, en équivalent primaire, représente environ 5 % de la consommation mondiale.
Tout le reste tombe sous la barre de 1 % de celle-ci. J'ai fait figurer les équivalents primaires pour les énergies purement électriques.
Les agro/biocarburants, que j'appelle « agricarburants » car ils ne sont pas bio, représentent 0,5 % de l'énergie mondiale, soit 1,5 % du pétrole mondial. C'est ridicule.
Néanmoins, afin de développer cette ressource, nous sommes déjà en train d'affamer une partie de la planète. (M. Claude Léonard s'étonne.)
En effet, il y a maintenant 15-20 ans que les Américains ont affecté la totalité de la hausse de leur production de maïs à la fabrication d'éthanol.
Le Mexique, pour le moment, peut encore payer des importations de maïs grâce à ses excédents pétroliers.
Ces derniers disparaîtront dans 4-5 ans, car la part mexicaine de la production du golfe du Mexique est en train de décliner.
Que se passera-t-il alors au Mexique ? Je ne sais pas, mais cela risque d'être intéressant !
Aujourd'hui, une pression absolument évidente s'exerce sur les cultures vivrières en raison du développement des agrocarburants. Ce n'est pas la seule : une autre est due au climat.
Cela me permet de répondre en partie à l'une des questions que vous m'avez posées : est-il intéressant de fixer des tarifs de rachat exorbitants ?
Ma réponse est non. C'est du gaspillage, à seule fin de se faire plaisir !
Dit autrement, tant qu'il y a de la croissance parce qu'il y a abondance de gaz, de charbon et de pétrole, une telle mesure sert uniquement à se donner bonne conscience en recyclant des surplus.
Le jour où l'économie sera durement atteinte parce que l'approvisionnement français en pétrole, en gaz et en charbon commencera à décliner, on arrêtera de se livrer à ce genre de plaisanteries.
C'est en 2004 que j'ai écrit pour la première fois que les subventions au photovoltaïque et à l'éolien s'arrêteraient lorsque surviendraient des récessions
justement dues aux problèmes que l'on prétend ainsi éviter. Je crois que nous y sommes.
J'en ai fini avec cette présentation des quelques éléments de réflexion qui, selon moi, doivent encadrer toute analyse sur les tarifs de l'électricité en particulier, et de l'énergie en général.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - En ce qui concerne les énergies non renouvelables, le pétrole est-il la source d'énergie la plus utilisée ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Oui, dans le mix mondial, le pétrole fournit 1/3 de l'énergie primaire.
Il représente plus de 40 % de l'énergie finale, c'est-à-dire celle qui est mise à la disposition des consommateurs. Le pétrole domine donc très largement le mix énergétique mondial.
Par ailleurs, dans le système de transport qui, aujourd'hui, est le « sang » de l'économie mondiale, la part du pétrole atteint 98 %.
C'est la raison pour laquelle, à l'heure actuelle, le pétrole pilote le PIB en volume.
Si demain la France se trouvait privée de moyens de transport, Paris mourrait de faim, il y aurait des émeutes et le pays s'effondrerait !
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - D'abord le pétrole, ensuite le gaz ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Non, ensuite le charbon !
Le pétrole représente un tiers de l'énergie primaire mondiale, le charbon 25 %, le gaz 20 %, la biomasse 10 %, le nucléaire et l'hydroélectricité 5 % chacun, et le reste de 1,5 % à 2 %.
Autre précision, le charbon sert essentiellement à produire de l'électricité, à hauteur des 2/3 des quantités extraites.
Symétriquement, la première source de production électrique dans le monde est le charbon, qui fournit environ 40 % de l'électricité mondiale.
Toujours pour fixer des ordres de grandeur, j'indique que, entre 1945 et aujourd'hui,
la production électrique mondiale est passée de 600 TWh, soit la production française actuelle, à 20 000 TWh.
L'accès massif et démocratique à l'électricité n'est pas le fait de la révolution industrielle, c'est un acquis de la deuxième moitié du XXe siècle.
Et c'est extrêmement fossile, les deux tiers de l'électricité mondiale sont produits à partir de combustibles fossiles, le charbon à 40 %, et le gaz, 25 %.
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - Je vous remercie, monsieur Jancovici.
Monsieur le rapporteur, j'imagine que vous aimeriez maintenant obtenir des réponses à vos questions liminaires ?
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - M. Jancovici a abordé les questions que je lui ai posées sous un certain angle.
Puisque vous avez parlé des volumes, monsieur Jancovici, pourriez-vous maintenant évoquer les coûts ? J'imagine que votre conclusion est qu'ils seront déterminés par les volumes ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Pour partie !
Les volumes détermineront également les politiques énergétiques.
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Pour répondre à la première question que vous m'avez posée au début de l'audition, monsieur le rapporteur, je n'ai pas lu en totalité le récent rapport de la Cour des comptes sur le coût de l'électricité nucléaire. J'en ai seulement lu la synthèse et j'ai eu plusieurs fois le plaisir de discuter avec Mme Pappalardo.
Selon moi, ce rapport est un exercice extrêmement salutaire, qui devrait être répété pour les autres formes d'énergie afin de définir les concepts et de bien préciser de quoi il est question !
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Absolument !
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - L'électricité d'origine nucléaire va-t-elle demeurer compétitive d'un point de vue économique ? Ma réponse est oui, même en tenant compte du coût des accidents possibles.
En effet, si l'on veut tenir compte des externalités pour le nucléaire, il faut également le faire pour toutes les autres énergies.
Par ailleurs, la production d'un MWh d'électricité à partir du charbon entraînant l'émission d'une tonne de CO2, si l'on fixe à 100 euros le coût de cette dernière, le coût de production du MWh d'électricité augmente de 100 euros,
100 euros par tonne de CO2 donc une hausse de 10 centimes par kilowattheure électrique pour le consommateur final. (1 MWh au charbon = 1 tonne de CO2)
Dans un marché européen dont la finalité est d'instaurer la concurrence partout et en permanence - ce qui à mes yeux est une ânerie sans nom pour l'électricité -,
comme le système s'ajuste, par la magie de la circulation des électrons, qui ne se stockent pas, non sur le coût le plus bas du dispositif de production, mais sur le plus élevé,...
... si l'on augmente de 100 euros le coût de production du mégawattheure par les centrales à charbon, on augmente de 100 euros le coût de production du mégawattheure pour tout le monde !
C'est toute la magie du marché libéralisé !
C'est donc une bêtise, non pas à cause de cette hausse du coût - je suis très favorable à des augmentations de prix de l'électricité pour engendrer des économies d'énergie -,
mais parce qu'on crée une rente qui va là où elle ne devrait pas aller.
Le nucléaire restera donc économique. Qu'est-ce qui est important pour la France ?
Premièrement, l'état de la balance du commerce extérieur ; deuxièmement, le taux de chômage ; troisièmement, l'état des comptes publics.
Je vais peut-être vous choquer, mais le pouvoir d'achat moyen des Français n'est pas mon premier sujet de préoccupation, car sa baisse est inévitable.
Plus on s'arc-boute sur le pouvoir d'achat, plus on dégrade les trois autres indicateurs que je viens d'évoquer.
La grande distribution a fait le bonheur du consommateur et le malheur de notre balance commerciale, ainsi que de l'emploi français !
Les subventions à l'énergie feront le bonheur de l'automobiliste pendant une courte période.
À cause de l'effet récessif des différents chocs pétroliers, elles aggraveront le chômage et la situation des comptes publics.
1) l'état de la balance du commerce extérieur ; 3) le taux de chômage ; 3) l'état des comptes publics.
Si l'on prend en considération les trois critères qui doivent importer,
le nucléaire est la source d'électricité dont l'incidence sur la balance commerciale est le plus faible.
Certes, nous dépendons des importations d'uranium, mais celles-ci ne représentent pas grand-chose dans le prix du kWh final.
Par ailleurs, on peut stocker l'uranium, ce qui laisse le temps de se retourner : si le Kazakhstan nous fait des misères, on s'adressera au Canada ; si le Canada nous fait des misères, on se tournera vers l'Australie ou le Niger !
En revanche, nous avons seulement trois mois de stock de pétrole, idem pour le gaz, et donc très peu de marge de manoeuvre,
comme nous avons pu le constater l'hiver dernier, lors de la vague de froid qui a entraîné une tension sur le marché du gaz. Les Russes et les Norvégiens font de nous ce qu'ils veulent
Les Norvégiens sont accommodants ; les Russes, je ne sais pas ce que cela va donner dans le temps...
Quoi qu'il en soit, nous sommes pieds et poings liés en ce qui concerne les importations de gaz.
L'Espagne, qui en raison de l'intermittence de la production, a dû doubler son parc éolien d'un parc de centrales à gaz à peu près de même puissance,
et qui produit aujourd'hui 2 kWh au gaz pour 1 kWh d'éolien, une situation dont elle se serait bien passé dans la crise qu'elle subit.
Le nucléaire représente donc un optimum pour la production d'électricité de masse.
C'est même la seule solution accessible en France : il n'est plus possible de noyer beaucoup de vallées,
l'éolien, à cause du caractère diffus et intermittent de sa production, ne tiendra qu'une place limitée,
de même que la biomasse. Les calculs d'ordre de grandeur mettent en lumière
que le potentiel de biomasse disponible pour fabriquer de l'électricité n'est pas très étendu, surtout si l'on doit vivre dans un monde où l'on utilisera moins d'engrais.
À mes yeux, le nucléaire est donc très compétitif, et ce pour de bonnes raisons.
Faut-il prolonger la durée de vie des centrales nucléaires existantes ? Je serais content qu'une telle décision soit prise, mais ce n'est ni à moi ni à vous d'en juger :
cette responsabilité incombe à l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire, l'ASN, qui a été créée, justement, pour que les décisions relatives au nucléaire ne soient pas le fait du prince.
Laissons l'ASN accomplir sa mission.
C'est pour moi un point de principe : soit on considère que l'ASN est techniquement compétente pour se prononcer sur l'état des installations nucléaires ;
soit on considère qu'elle ne l'est pas, mais alors on remplace les personnes qui se trouvent à sa tête.
Si je n'ai pas confiance en l'un de mes collaborateurs, je ne passe pas derrière lui pour refaire son travail : je le vire !
Il revient à l'exploitant de tenir compte des recommandations de l'ASN.
Pour la filière graphite-gaz, il faut savoir que l'autorité de sûreté de l'époque, qui était une direction du ministère, avait critiqué ce type de réacteurs et exigé d'EDF des aménagements.
EDF, jugeant les coûts trop élevés, a alors décidé de renoncer à cette filière.
Il doit en aller de même pour la prolongation de la durée de vie des centrales nucléaires : il incombe à l'exploitant de faire ses calculs et de mettre en oeuvre les recommandations de l'ASN ou de renoncer à cette prolongation.
En tant que citoyen, je considère que prolonger la durée de vie des centrales nucléaires serait une bonne chose sur le plan économique.
Cela étant, si l'ASN estime préférable de ne pas le faire, mon sentiment est qu'il faut construire de nouvelles centrales.
À mes yeux, les sources d'énergie fossiles comportent globalement beaucoup plus de risques que le nucléaire.
Jusqu'à présent, je n'ai pas évoqué les risques globaux, notamment le changement climatique.
Les « printemps arabes » sont, selon moi, très largement une conséquence de la contrainte énergie-climat.
Il est évident que des déstabilisations socioéconomiques massives vont apparaître dans un monde où l'énergie fossile se fait rare et où le climat se dérègle rapidement.
Je préfère, de très loin, vivre avec le risque réel mais maîtrisé lié à l'existence d'une centrale nucléaire
qu'avec le risque totalement non maîtrisé que recèle un monde devenant violent et guerrier à cause du manque de pétrole et du dérèglement du climat.
Pour avoir bien étudié la question depuis cinq ans, je pense que, malheureusement, cette éventualité est loin d'être une simple vue de l'esprit.
3° Les tarifs actuels de l'électricité me paraissent-ils refléter fidèlement le « coût réel » de l'électricité ? Si l'on inclut les externalités liées aux sources d'énergie fossiles,
La réponse est non. Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que si la tonne de CO2 émise coûte 100 euros, le consommateur doit payer le kWh, 10c plus cher.
Je persiste et signe : l'électricité ne vaut pas assez cher.
Cela étant, la hausse de son prix doit profiter non pas aux gaziers et aux charbonniers,
mais à l'État, via les taxes, qui assurent un recyclage national de l'argent. Les impôts sont nécessaires, toute la question est de bien les choisir.
Les taxes sur l'énergie, à mes yeux, sont de très bons impôts.
Elles ne font pas obstacle, par ailleurs, à la promotion des modes de production électrique les plus favorables à la baisse du taux de chômage, à la balance commerciale et à l'équilibre des finances publiques.
Comment les tarifs devraient-ils évoluer selon moi ?
Je pense qu'il faut mettre en place un tarif progressif de l'électricité, et non pas dégressif. Plus on consomme d'électricité, plus on doit payer cher.
Certes, une telle mesure est antinataliste, mais tous ceux qui s'intéressent de près à la fiscalité savent très bien qu'une bonne taxe exclut les niches.
Les situations particulières doivent être prises en compte grâce à des mesures particulières, pas de niche.
Une bonne taxe sur l'énergie a une assiette large, n'admet pas de dérogations et donne de la visibilité.
Quand on commence à faire des cas particuliers, c'est le début de la fin.
La situation des familles nombreuses qui ont des difficultés à payer leur facture d'électricité doit être réglée en tant que telle, par exemple en leur versant directement une allocation par enfant.
Par ailleurs, pour le gaz et le pétrole, il faut bien sûr également mettre en place une taxe carbone.
Pour l'électricité, le problème est largement réglé par le système européen des quotas d'émission de CO2. Cependant, ce dernier devrait être complété de deux façons.
Tout d'abord, l'application de la directive devrait, d'entrée de jeu, être prolongée jusqu'à la fin de vie des centrales électriques, afin de donner de la visibilité aux acteurs économiques jusqu'en 2050.
Voilà 25 ans qu'ils me font vivre, je les connais donc bien : sans visibilité, ils ne font rien.
Le grand paradoxe est qu'un acteur économique ne sait pas payer de lui-même sa prime d'assurance : il ne calcule pas l'espérance mathématique de ses pertes pour déterminer son action,
et par conséquent, en l'absence de visibilité sur le prix auquel il achètera ses quotas d'ici à 2050, il ne fera rien !
La décision de prolonger la directive jusqu'en 2050 ne dépend pas des Français, mais elle peut éventuellement résulter du lobbying que les Français seraient avisés d'exercer à Bruxelles la décision de prolonger la directive jusqu'en 2050,
pour que soit affiché dès à présent un prix croissant dans le temps pour les quotas mis aux enchères.
Tant que l'on manquera de visibilité s'agissant de la contrainte à venir pour des infrastructures qui durent cinquante ans et qui, notamment pour le nucléaire,
demandent des immobilisations de capitaux pendant huit ans avant que ne soit produit le premier kWh, il n'y aura rien à espérer de ces acteurs financiarisés que sont la quasi-totalité des producteurs d'électricité du Vieux Continent.
La financiarisation a beaucoup raccourci les échéances. Bruxelles fait fausse route en préconisant une telle libéralisation : le système se porte beaucoup plus mal.
Le seul moyen de corriger à peu près les choses est de mettre en place des quotas avec un prix minimum d'enchères annoncé à l'avance et quarante ans de préavis.
Cela n'interdit pas, ensuite, de moduler à la baisse ou à la hausse le rythme de l'augmentation du prix, mais il faut donner de la visibilité :
c'est le maître mot dans le monde économique.
Si le cadre fiscal change tous les quatre matins, il est à peu près certain qu'il n'en sortira rien de sympathique.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Cela ne peut se faire qu'au niveau européen ?
Oui, c'est pourquoi je recommande un lobbying actif de la France à Bruxelles.
L'Allemagne prétend vouloir à la fois lutter contre le changement climatique - elle s'est dotée d'un plan très ambitieux à cet égard - et sortir du nucléaire. Soit, mais il lui faut des quotas très élevés : si elle s'en sort, tant mieux !
J'ai déjà répondu à votre question sur les mécanismes de soutien aux énergies renouvelables.
Selon moi, ils sont gérés en dépit du bon sens. Il faudrait plutôt mettre en place un dispositif transversal.
J'en ai justement présenté un devant la Cour des comptes il n'y a pas longtemps : le coût à la tonne de CO2 évitée.
Supposons que l'on envisage de prendre une mesure dont l'effet escompté est d'éviter d'émettre du CO2 et, très accessoirement, d'importer des combustibles fossiles.
Par exemple, il peut s'agir d'instaurer une prime à la casse pour les voitures ou une prime à l'installation des éoliennes.
Cette mesure va déformer notre avenir : en comparant ce que serait celui-ci avec ou sans mesure, à la fois sur le plan de l'équation économique d'ensemble
et sur celui des émissions de CO2, on déduit le coût à la tonne de CO2 évitée.
Ainsi, si l'on produit des panneaux photovoltaïques en France, le coût à la tonne de CO2 évitée est de l'ordre de 10 000 euros :
il faut dépenser 10 000 euros d'argent public pour éviter l'émission d'une tonne de CO2.
Si l'on produit de tels matériels en Chine, le solde est négatif, le temps de retour sur carbone. Autrement dit, on subventionne une augmentation des émissions de CO2.
pour un panneau fabriqué en Chine grâce à de l'électricité produite à partir de charbon chinois étant de l'ordre de trente ans, ce qui est supérieur à la durée de vie du panneau.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Pourriez-vous reprendre cette explication ?
Le panneau photovoltaïque chinois est fabriqué avec de l'électricité dont la production entraîne l'émission de 800 à 900 grammes de CO2 par kWh
contre 130 ou 140 grammes de CO2 par kWh pour un panneau fabriqué en France.
Pour un kWh d'électricité chinoise consommée pour fabriquer le panneau,
il faut en récupérer 6 à 8 - c'est plutôt 8 - une fois qu'il a été installé en France.
Il se trouve que la quantité de kWh nécessaire pour fabriquer un panneau représente de l'ordre de trois ans de fonctionnement de ce dernier.
Comme il faut récupérer 8 fois plus d'électricité en France que ce qui a été consommé en Chine pour la fabrication, on en arrive à 25 années de fonctionnement,
et à 30 en prenant en compte les équipements annexes.
Le panneau fabriqué en Chine doit donc fonctionner 30 ans pour que les émissions de carbone liées à sa fabrication soient compensées.
Par conséquent, quand on a subventionné le développement du photovoltaïque en France,
on a subventionné un déséquilibre commercial, une non-création d'emplois dans notre pays et une hausse des émissions de CO2 !
M. Claude Léonard. - Tout à fait !
On a donc eu faux sur toute la ligne, sans même parler du déséquilibre des finances publiques !
Et je suis écologiste, c'est-à-dire soucieux de préserver un monde stable pour mes enfants, en termes aussi bien de climat que de ressources biologiques et énergétiques !
Le monde a toujours comporté des risques. L'idée d'un monde sans risques est une vue de l'esprit ; il faut simplement choisir les bons.
D'autres mesures que celle que je viens d'évoquer seraient efficaces, mais elles sont moins démagogiques.
Par exemple, augmenter le prix de l'essence est une mesure qui présente un coût à la tonne de CO2 évitée extrêmement intéressant.
Par ailleurs, cela permettrait d'alléger le déficit de la balance commerciale - il a été de 70 Mds d'euros l'an dernier (2011) -, de créer de l'emploi en France et d'équilibrer les finances publiques.
Sauf que ça oblige à dire aux français, le genre de choses peu sympathiques que je viens de vous évoquer...
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Je comprends qu'une augmentation du prix de l'essence puisse permettre d'améliorer les finances publiques, mais en quoi créerait-elle de l'emploi ?
Parce qu'il faudra gérer un certain nombre de transitions, notamment en matière d'urbanisme.
L'urbanisme actuel ne résistera pas à une forte contrainte sur l'approvisionnement pétrolier,
car une partie de la population vivant aujourd'hui dans les zones périurbaines sera mise hors du jeu économique, donc au chômage.
Ce phénomène a déjà commencé : des poches de chômage apparaissent dans les zones périurbaines, par petites touches pour le moment, mais cette tendance va se renforcer.
Il faudra remplacer les voitures actuelles par des modèles de plus petite cylindrée. La mesure la plus efficace pour les trente prochaines années n'est pas de passer à la voiture électrique :
c'est de remplacer des voitures qui consomment 6 litres de carburant aux 100 kilomètres par des 2 CV nouveau modèle,
dont la vitesse plafonnera à 110km/h et la puissance moteur à 30cv, qui pèseront 500kg et consommeront 1,5L aux 100km. Nos ingénieurs sauront très bien concevoir de tels véhicules.
Si Renault et Peugeot se lancent dans la construction de ce genre de voitures, ce sera bénéfique pour l'emploi. Sans cela, ces sociétés feront faillite.
Voyez General Motors, qui ne savait fabriquer que des voitures consommant 10-15L aux 100km au moment du choc pétrolier de 2008.
La TIPP a sauvé l'industrie automobile française, il faut le dire : la TIPP a sauvé l'industrie automobile française.
En forçant pendant cinquante ans les constructeurs français à concevoir de petits moteurs et en amortissant les variations de prix du marché par des taxes qui dépendent des volumes
et non des prix hors taxes, on a considérablement stabilisé le système.
Si je préconise une augmentation du prix de l'électricité,
ce n'est pas pour faire de la peine au consommateur, c'est pour forcer le Français, qui n'en peut mais, à payer la prime d'assurance qui permettra de stabiliser le pays.
Le but du jeu, ce n'est pas de faire souffrir le consommateur pour le plaisir, le but c'est de stabiliser le pays !
Nous serons certainement tous d'accord ici pour considérer qu'un pays qui n'est pas en paix est un pays dans lequel la prospérité est difficile à trouver.
Il existe des situations qui sont des sources potentielles de conflits, y compris en France. Il peut s'agir aussi de guerres civiles larvées, d'émeutes, etc.
Le mécanisme de soutien aux différentes énergies renouvelables me paraît-il mal ciblé ? Oui. Il faudrait réaliser une étude préalable du coût à la tonne de CO2 évitée
lorsque l'on envisage de prendre la moindre mesure budgétaire destinée à faire baisser les émissions de CO2. Je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas prendre de telles mesures, je dis qu'il faut procéder à une analyse préalable.
Enfin, le prix de l'électricité en Europe devrait-il mieux refléter le coût lié aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre ? J'ai déjà répondu par l'affirmative à cette question. Oui, 25 fois oui.
À mon avis, il faut lutter pour éviter les incohérences entre la liberté, pour les pays européens, de choisir leur politique d'investissements électriques et
l'obligation, pour l'Union européenne, de répercuter les variations de coût résultant des différents choix nationaux sur l'ensemble de la plaque européenne.
Autrement dit, si les Allemands prennent une décision qui entraîne une augmentation du prix de l'électricité chez eux, par le jeu du système qui a été mis en place, tous les États voisins en supportent les conséquences, ce qui n'est pas normal.
Ou bien les pays européens définissent tous ensemble une politique commune et en partagent les coûts - cette option serait probablement mon premier choix -,
ou bien chacun est libre de sa politique et en assume seul les coûts, sans que des interconnexions permettent
par exemple aux Allemands d'importer de l'électricité quand ils décident de fermer leurs centrales nucléaires.
C'est un principe de responsabilisation des États.
Si les États veulent conserver une marge de manoeuvre, ils doivent assumer la responsabilité correspondante.
Sinon, il faut mutualiser et aller vers plus de fédéralisme, ce qui n'est probablement pas la plus mauvaise option.
C'est un choix !
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - Je vous félicite, monsieur Jancovici, vous avez bien mené votre exposé.
Très sincèrement, je ne savais pas très bien où vous alliez nous mener au début de cette audition ! (Sourires.)
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - J'ajouterai une dernière précision : il ressort implicitement de tout ce que j'ai dit que l'accès au capital privé, dans un monde qui connaîtra une récession tous les trois ans, va devenir considérablement plus difficile.
En creux, cela signifie qu'une forme de renationalisation des systèmes électriques ne serait probablement pas une mauvaise idée.
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - Mes chers collègues, souhaitez-vous poser des questions complémentaires ?
La parole est à M. le rapporteur.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Effectivement, monsieur Jancovici, votre discours s'écarte de ce que nous avons entendu jusqu'à maintenant. Je pense à votre préconisation d'augmenter le prix de l'électricité.
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - Elle ne me surprend pas !
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Vous affirmez également qu'il faut réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de serre si l'on veut éviter un changement climatique qui nous conduirait à une récession importante.
Cela signifie qu'il faut réduire la dépendance au pétrole par des économies d'énergie, ...
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Essentiellement dans un premier temps.
... puis renforcer l'efficacité énergétique ?
Également. Il y a un bon mix des deux à trouver. Je prendrai un exemple. Des calculs ont été réalisés pour le compte d'EDF, que je suis autorisé à vous communiquer.
L'optimum économique, dans le bâtiment, n'est pas de ramener la consommation d'énergie primaire à 50kWh/m²/an ;
il est plutôt de l'abaisser aux alentours de 100 kWh/m²/an et d'augmenter la part de l'électricité au détriment du chauffage au gaz et au fioul, en isolant, mais sans excès.
Ramener la consommation à 80-100 kWh/m²/an est déjà une jolie performance pour un certain nombre de bâtiments, notamment dans l'ancien.
Par ailleurs, passer au chauffage électrique n'empêche pas de faire des choix intelligents : on peut très bien recourir à des pompes à chaleur.
Grâce à un ensemble de telles mesures, on divise par 6 à 8 les émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans le bâtiment et
on diminue les importations de produits pétroliers et gaziers.
De surcroît, c'est excellent pour l'emploi puisque cela donne du travail aux maçons. Le véritable défi est de revaloriser le travail manuel aux yeux de nos enfants.
C'est très cohérent avec ce que j'ai dit précédemment : dans un monde où l'énergie sera plus rare, tout le monde ne pourra pas travailler dans un bureau, de plus en plus de gens vont devoir se remettre à transpirer ! (Sourires.)
Un mix entre les économies d'énergie, par l'isolation, et l'électrification, avec le recours à une électricité produite sans émissions de CO2, me paraît constituer le bon arbitrage.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Vous n'êtes pas opposé au nucléaire.
Mme Laurence Rossignol. - Non, vous y êtes même très favorable !
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Tout à fait !
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - En ce qui concerne les énergies renouvelables, en revanche, vous avez émis des réserves.
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - J'ai souligné que toutes les énergies renouvelables ne se valaient pas. Nous devons être sélectifs et employer un critère de bonne gestion.
Si la contrainte doit nous mettre dans une situation financière difficile, il faut faire particulièrement attention à l'efficacité de la dépense budgétaire.
Installer un poêle à bois dans une maison de campagne, après l'avoir isolée, ou un chauffe-eau solaire est une excellente idée, énergies renouvelables !
mais poser partout dans le pays des panneaux photovoltaïques est une idée saugrenue !
Il faut donc être sélectif et bien savoir pourquoi on prend telle décision plutôt que telle autre.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Êtes-vous favorable à un renouvelable de proximité ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Ça dépend. Pour l'électricité, ça n'a pas de sens, mais ça en a pour la chaleur.
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - Le chauffe-eau solaire est tout de même fabriqué en Chine !
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Il peut très bien être fabriqué en France, à condition que l'on accepte de le payer plus cher. C'est une affaire de choix :
le malheur du consommateur fait le bonheur du salarié, et inversement.
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - Vous avez très bien démontré tout à l'heure qu'en subventionnant le photovoltaïque, on favorisait le déficit commercial et l'emploi en Chine au détriment de l'emploi en France, ainsi que la production de CO2.
Cette démonstration vaut également pour le chauffe-eau solaire !
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Tout dépend du système d'incitation mis en place.
Même pour le photovoltaïque, le prix du système posé varie du simple au triple selon les pays. La France est un pays de profiteurs, les effets d'aubaine sont absolument monstrueux.
Encore une fois, tout dépend de la manière d'organiser le système.
Si l'on importe des chauffe-eau solaires de Chine pour un montant inférieur au coût du gaz nécessaire pour produire l'eau chaude sanitaire, c'est une bonne affaire.
Je ne prétends pas être dès à présent capable d'établir une liste exhaustive et régionalisée des bonnes mesures.
En revanche, je sais comment déterminer la bonne réponse en fonction de la zone géographique considérée et de ce que l'on veut faire.
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - Quoi qu'il en soit, j'ai apprécié votre démonstration. Ce n'était pas le sujet, mais je regrette que nous ne vous ayons pas questionné davantage sur le transport.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Il a parlé des petites voitures !
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - En ce qui concerne le transport, il faut augmenter le prix de l'essence et, dans le même temps, planter des « banderilles » dans le dos des constructeurs pour les inciter à réduire la consommation moyenne de leurs véhicules.
Je vais vous livrer un calcul d'ordres de grandeur qui vous intéressera peut-être.
Le coût des investissements pour les infrastructures au titre du projet du Grand Paris sera à peu près de 60 Mds d'euros, avant que n'intervienne le fameux « facteur pi », entre le budget prévisionnel et le coût réel.
Par parenthèse, Mme Cécile Duflot, qui s'exprimait l'autre jour sur une chaîne de radio, a posé une question qui m'a fait sourire : qu'est-ce qui coûte finalement le double de ce qui était initialement prévu, à part l'EPR ?
La réponse est simple : tout prototype industriel ! Cela est vrai aussi dans le domaine du développement des logiciels...
Pour en revenir au Grand Paris,
cette dépense d'environ 60 milliards d'euros débouchera, selon nos calculs, sur un déplacement de l'ordre de 2 % à 3 % de la mobilité motorisée des Franciliens...
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - Explication ?
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Soit l'on implante des lignes de transport en commun dans des zones denses, où déjà très peu de gens utilisent leur voiture,
et l'on obtient essentiellement un report modal pour des personnes qui ne se déplaçaient pas en voiture, ainsi que de l'induction de trafic :
des gens profitent de l'existence d'un moyen de transport en commun en bas de chez eux pour aller se balader alors que sinon ils seraient restés à la maison !
Dans ce schéma, le vrai report modal au détriment de la voiture est marginal.
Soit l'on implante des moyens de transport en commun dans des zones peu denses - par exemple on construit une station de métro sur le plateau de Saclay, au milieu de la pampa -,
et alors on n'attire personne, le rayon de la zone d'attraction d'une gare n'étant que de un à deux kilomètres.
Les habitants d'une zone peu dense ont tous une voiture et la nouvelle offre de transports en commun ne les attirera guère.
Soit dit en passant, le projet de desserte par le métro du plateau de Saclay aura pour premier effet d'accroître les constructions à usage tertiaire dans cette zone.
Le métro n'étant pas encore construit, les résidants se déplaceront en voiture.
Le jour où la construction du métro sera achevée, ils ne déménageront pas pour aller s'installer ailleurs.
Un tel projet était probablement une très bonne idée en 1930 ou en 1940, mais il est totalement anachronique aujourd'hui.
M. Jean Desessard, rapporteur. - Vous parlez du projet du Grand Paris pour les transports ?
Les projets prévus pour la petite couronne sont intelligents, ceux qui concernent la grande couronne ne sont absolument pas à la hauteur des enjeux.
C'est donc du gaspillage d'argent public.
Je le répète, pour un coût de 60 milliards d'euros, on obtiendra un déplacement de 2 % à 3 % de la mobilité motorisée.
Je reprends maintenant l'exemple des petites voitures à faible consommation.
Si, après avoir poussé Renault et Peugeot à produire des 2 CV consommant 1,5 litre aux 100 kilomètres,
on instaure une prime à la casse couvrant la totalité du prix d'achat d'un tel véhicule - 10 000 euros - au bénéfice de tous les ménages franciliens qui mettront à la casse leur voiture qui consomme 6L aux 100 km,
la dépense totale sera de 60 milliards d'euros, puisque l'on compte 6 millions de voitures en Île-de-France.
Pour la même somme, dans le premier cas, on change la vie de 3 % des utilisateurs de voiture ; dans le second, on change la vie de tous les automobilistes, pour la même somme d'argent public.
Si l'on veut éviter que, dans le même temps, les recettes de la TIPP ne s'effondrent parce que la consommation de carburant aura été divisée par trois, il faut multiplier le prix de l'essence par trois. (M. le président sourit.)
Avec une telle mesure, on résout le problème posé à urbanisme constant, car ce n'est pas en dix ans que l'on peut faire déménager des gens depuis des banlieues lointaines :
il faut de 50 à 100 ans pour modifier la forme des villes en version "sympathique"
Pour répondre à la contrainte pétrolière qui commence à s'exercer aujourd'hui et qui deviendra particulièrement prégnante dans les 10-15 prochaines années,
la seule possibilité est de diminuer très rapidement, à technologie constante, la consommation unitaire des véhicules.
et à ce compte là, vous sauvez la stabilité dans une bonne partie de la couronne francilienne.
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - La parole est à M. Claude Léonard.
M. Claude Léonard. - Je vous ai trouvé très sévère à l'égard des éoliennes et du caractère intermittent de leur production électrique.
Mon département en compte environ 200, et quelques installations vont encore être réalisées. Je le traverse trois ou quatre fois par semaine, grâce à une voiture qui ne consomme pas 1,5 litre aux 100 kilomètres,
et je vois rarement ces éoliennes à l'arrêt. Se mettent-elles systématiquement en marche lorsqu'elles me voient arriver ? (Sourires.)
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - Il y a des chiffres officiels.
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Comme vous le savez, monsieur le sénateur, la production électrique injectée sur le réseau est fonction du cube de la vitesse du vent.
Si la vitesse de rotation des pales double, la puissance injectée sur le réseau est multipliée par huit. Or nous avons du mal à apprécier la vitesse de rotation avec nos sens.
M. Claude Léonard. - Effectivement, mais il faudrait le faire savoir au grand public, qui ignore ce fait et raisonne selon une logique du tout ou rien : soit les éoliennes tournent, soit elles ne tournent pas.
M. Jean-Marc Jancovici. - Voici un début de réponse à votre question.
(M. Jean-Marc Jancovici commente le document 25.)
Des physiciens, au terme d'un long travail de fourmis, de telles informations n'étant pas centralisées, ont récupéré
auprès de RTE et de plusieurs autres transporteurs d'électricité européens la puissance injectée sur le réseau
par l'ensemble des éoliennes d'Espagne, d'Allemagne, de France, de Grande Bretagne, et du Danemark, entre septembre 2012 et mars 2011, le pas de temps étant l'heure, si ma mémoire est bonne.
Soit une dépression est installée sur l'Atlantique et toutes les éoliennes produisent, qu'elles soient en Allemagne, en Espagne, en France, au Royaume-Uni, etc. ;
soit un anticyclone est installé sur l'Atlantique, et il ne souffle qu'un peu de vent résiduel sur Gibraltar ou dans le couloir rhodanien.
Ce graphique montre que, en moyenne, sur les six mois considérés, la puissance injectée ne dépasse jamais la moitié de la puissance installée, qui est de 65 000 mégawatts.
Il montre également que la puissance garantie ne représente qu'un petit pourcentage de la puissance installée.
L'intermittence induite, qui doit être compensée soit par des centrales hydrauliques, soit par des centrales à gaz, apparaît clairement.
Les Espagnols ont opté pour des centrales à gaz, ce qui leur coûte maintenant très cher en importations de gaz et en émissions de CO2.
Ils publient de très beaux communiqués de presse quand c'est la production éolienne qui domine, mais la production des centrales à gaz est trois fois plus souvent dans ce cas !
Les Allemands ont choisi de compenser avec des centrales à charbon.
Quant aux Danois, ils ont trouvé une solution géniale.
Quand le vent souffle, comme le pays est trop petit pour absorber sa propre production éolienne,
il l'exporte vers les pays avec lesquels il est interconnecté, c'est-à-dire l'Allemagne et la Norvège.
Le Danemark devant absolument se débarrasser de cette électricité pour sauvegarder l'équilibre du réseau électrique, il est prêt à la vendre à n'importe quel prix.
À quel prix croyez-vous que la Norvège est disposée à la payer ? À un prix qui reflète le coût de production marginal d'un barrage,
soit le coût des trois minutes de travail nécessaires aux ouvriers norvégiens pour ouvrir et fermer le « robinet »... c'est zéro...
Les Danois ont donc subventionné une industrie qui vend à l'exportation à un coût marginal quasiment nul.
En revanche, lorsque le vent ne souffle pas et qu'ils ont besoin d'électricité, ils en achètent au producteur norvégien, qui leur fait payer le prix fort puisqu'il s'agit d'électricité de pointe !
Voilà pourquoi les Danois ont finalement mis fin aux subventions à l'éolien, qui profitaient en réalité au producteur d'électricité hydraulique norvégien.
Les Norvégiens, eux, sont ravis et tout à fait favorables à l'électricité d'origine éolienne, comme, du reste, les vendeurs de gaz !
J'ai assisté, en marge de la conférence de Copenhague sur le changement climatique en décembre 2009, au meeting de l'International Gas Union.
J'étais certainement le seul Français présent dans la salle et je n'ai pas aperçu un seul journaliste. Je puis vous garantir que les gaziers, tous en coeur, ont plébiscité l'éolien ! (Sourires.)
M. Ladislas Poniatowski, président. - Il nous reste à vous remercier et à vous féliciter de votre prestation, monsieur Jancovici.